I don't like being put in a situation where I have to defend
you. I'm just going to keep it 100. Uh but
>> Every person I hear preach about liberal values doesn't
seem to really uphold those values. Listen, I straight up hate
you, bro, but I will defend your right to say stupid Hasan.
>> So, let's let's check out the Ben Shapiro clip. A little
bit of them freaking out. All right, little little bit of Ben
freaking out about Cenk and Hasan.
[__] and Cenk wake up >> very online personalities,
left-wing
who are beloved by a lot of the mainstream media in the United
States.
Both supporters of various terrorist groups and foreign gov-
>> What part of mainstream media loves Hasan or Cenk?
I don't think that's true. I think that's already false. I think
Ben is already lying.
Hasan [__] and Cenk Uygur are loved by the corporate
media.
Cenk has literally been yelling about how the corporate media
is evil for like a decade. Is he really loved? I feel like he
would be the opposite of loved. In fact, he would not be liked
at all.
>> Both supporters of various terrorist groups and foreign
governments
This big story over the course of the last few days that the
UK has denied entry to them. Again, according to
the New York Times, the British Home Office said in an email
statement, the authorizations for the two American commentators
have been canceled because their presence in Britain quote may
not be conducive to the public good.
The Home Office said a decision to deny entry for that reason
was based solely on an assessment of the potential risk an individual
might pose to British society. The statement said nothing, for
example, about their criticism of Israel. There is no evidence
to this point that that's what this is about. The UK Tom- >> Wait,
hold on. Say that again. >> to British society.
For that reason was based solely on an assessment of the potential
risk an individual might pose to British
>> What risk would they pose to British >> canceled
because their presence in Britain quote may not be conducive
to the public good.
>> May not be conducive to the public good. >> The
Home Office said a decision to deny entry for that reason was
based solely on an assessment of the potential risk an individual
might pose to British
>> Okay, where are Cenk and Hasan getting the idea that
it was over their comments on Israel then? Cuz that seems to
be pretty clearly to me what it would be
I don't know how you consider them like bad or evil in any other
way,
yeah, I don't I I I have no idea. >> The statement said
nothing, for example, about their criticism of Israel. And there
is no evidence to this point that that's what this is about.
The UK Times, the Sunday Times, Times of London,
reported that it did have to do with their anti-Semitic views.
Quote, the decision to block Uygur from traveling to the UK is
understood to have been based on several grounds, including fears
that his presence would risk exacerbating anti-Semitism due to
his rhetoric since the October 7th attacks in 2023. This has
included repeating classic anti-Semitic tropes, such as the claim
that Israel controls America. So, >> So, somebody is reporting
that.
Why do you Do they just report like that? Do they just talk about
like that with no basis whatsoever, Ben? Is that how that work,
dog? >> Again, this this reporting is the basis for why
Cenk and Uygur are claiming
>> Okay, but
wouldn't the reporting have a basis in and of itself?
Would there would there really be no basis for that reporting
whatsoever,
>> that they are being banned for their feelings on Israel.
Uygur himself
is suggesting that he is not anti-Semitic, right? He's just
Now, as I mentioned before,
this is a distinction without any practical difference. If you
are calling for the destruction of the Jewish state, which exists
in the here and now, you're not having a prospective conversation
in 1920 about whether there ought to be a Jewish state in the
Middle East or not. It exists. It's been existing for 80 years.
You're not calling for the destruction of Pakistan, a Muslim
only state. You're not calling for the destruction of any of
the dozens of other states around the world. You're only calling
for the destruction of the Jewish state, which would entail the
murder of millions of
Are they calling for the violent destruction of the state?
Either of them.
Are they saying we need to nuke Israel? Are either of them saying
that?
I just it's so goofy. >> Uh part of why Cenk and Hasan
were banned is probably that it's fresh off the back of a bunch
of right-wingers getting blocked from attending a very recent
Tommy Robinson rally, and there is broad debate about double
standards going on in the UK at the moment.
Okay, that could be it. Let's do a quick segment on this. We'll
see We'll see what Cenk and Ana have to say, okay? >> The
Times of Israel had published uh a an article about the various
organizations that are trying to ban Hasan [__] from
the UK. And those organizations are the Community Security Trust.
That's a British charity, Leadership Council, and the Board of
Deputies of British So, these are the groups that were campaigning
behind the scenes to try to get you and Hasan. At first Hasan,
and I'm sure later you, uh banned from entry to the UK. >> Yeah,
so well, that leaves a couple questions. So, um what other groups
connected to Israel is the UK government getting orders from?
Because you can't say it's not orders because they said ban these
guys and with no evidence and no justification, and then we were
banned. So, uh do you have other groups? Do you have Muslim groups
who were able to just get everyone banned that they wanted? No,
you could say anything you want about Muslims and you're not
going to get banned. And I'm
I do think that's probably wrong. If there were right-wingers
banned in the UK over the same thing. Like, if right-wingers
were banned in the UK or banned from entering the UK to go to
a Tommy Robinson rally, I do think that's probably for her anti,
you know, anti-Islam, like Islamophobic rhetoric or something.
It could be. I'd have to see why they got banned. What exactly
were they saying that was >> In the UK they have different
rules than us, so some people that have said uh against Muslims
have gotten banned. But have there been giant groups connected
to other foreign governments that got it done? No, okay? So,
and I don't think they should be banned, either. I believe in
freedom of speech. So, but Zack Polanski made a good point. He's
the head of the Green Party in in the UK, and he said, "Wait,
how's this connected to anti-Semitism?" He said, "I'm sure I
believe that Israel's government has done genocidal >> Yeah,
I know Smotrich and Ben-Gvir are both banned from the UK, as
well. >> actions. So, am I anti-Semitic?
>> Like, [clears throat] this is insane. But, guys, 63%
of Americans are against the current government of Israel. Are
they all anti-Semitic? Millions of >> So, why >> this
can be called banned. What it is I mean, are you really calling
this not banned? Are we really going to say this actually doesn't
count as banned? It seems a little absurd, right?
To say this doesn't like they're canceling people's visas.
>> Hey, uh and did did did they ban any of these people
for attacking Representative Andy Levin and getting him out of
driving out of him out of office? Um so, no, uh they don't care
if you actually attack people like they attacked Andy Levin,
or if they go after Zack Polanski, or any other people. >> Well,
I assume I assume the thing is is they're going to be like, "Well,
actually, if they just wanted a tourist visa and they weren't
going to do any, you know, media events while they were there,
then technically they would be allowed to enter, maybe."
But, I don't even know
I don't even know if that would be the
Right? I think that's the argument on not banned is because like
technically you could get a tourist visa, maybe, to just go and
like see sites if you basically But, then you better believe
they'd be watching you, right, if you're banned from a different
kind of visa?
Hasan should do that. Hasan should talk about how he wants to
go to England and see the sites. He wants to go to Wales or something.
>> He should
He should do that. He should apply for a different one. >> Peace
activists are our allies. The only thing they care about is if
you go out go after the government of Israel, cuz these groups
don't really care that much about people. In fact, they're willing
to throw people under a bus and go, "No, if you say anything
against the genocide, that means you're against All are for genocide."
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Only Nazis and weird pro-Israel groups
say that. No one else says that. We certainly don't say that.
But, pro-Israel groups say, "Yes, you must say it's all No, I'm
not going to lie on your behalf and smear If you want to be weirdly
anti-Semitic and say that you have to blame all for what the
government of Israel has done, well, that's up to the United
Kingdom because apparently they're anti-Semites, vicious anti-Semites
cuz I've never criticized people. So, they're telling us that
the government of Israel represents all and then when they do
a genocide, all wanted to do a genocide. So, you should ask,
why is the government of the United Kingdom so deeply anti-Semitic?
So, and let alone what Ben Shapiro did just say this? Wait, did
he say
Hold on. I thought I thought Cenk is saying that not all support
the
And that only other people say that and they're racist. I didn't
think it was Ben said something different, which is Cenk wants
to kill every person in
Is that not very different? >> God forbid. You know, let
me real quick. Dave Rubin, but Dave Rubin went on Jubilee. And
uh he had the audacity to say the war in Gaza ended and there
are no more Israelis occupying the Gaza Strip and there's no
more bombing taking place.
So, like I know that Dave Rubin is like an extra level of um
stupid. Like he's really dumb. He's like one of the dumbest people
on the planet. But it does raise the question.
>> Wait, Rubin's not one of the people who started with
the Young Turks, is he? He's not. I think he is though.
It didn't Rubin get his start on the Young Turks or something?
He did? Okay. So, Ana knows firsthand just how stupid Dave Rubin
is. Let's go. >> Are all Zionists this dumb or are some
of them just lying or are some of them just uninformed and they
don't know? They're like closing their eyes and they're totally
blind to what the government they support has been doing for
nearly 3 years straight. >> Are there Zionists who are
lying about the genocide? Of course, there's a massive number.
They're And so, but are they all lying or are they just purposely
blinding themselves to reality? So, there's a everybody's different,
so there's different categories. Like in the case of Dave Rubin,
it's not that he doesn't know. He's obviously lying. >> I
will say it's not just lies, it is also like a
a very very concerted,
measured,
tactical, planned
effort to obfuscate information.
Like Like the Israeli government in terms of like details on
the war crimes that are being done, in terms of all the problems
they have, how they've conducted the campaigns both in Gaza and
Lebanon so far, like they for a very, very, very long time were
they took it to the extreme
covering this stuff up, okay?
Now, with Lebanon, they kind of just the cat's out of the bag
and they're just going for it. It's a little different, all right,
but at least during Gaza, it was pretty extreme the the media
blackout that they had, that they were able to put into place,
right? You almost had to be on some sort of alternative media
to really see what was going on. >> He's a giant liar,
a pathological liar. Almost everything he says is a lie. And
he when he after [clears throat] he left here, uh he made up
fantastical stories having no connection to reality at all. And
so he's he's has no conscience whatsoever. So, as Netanyahu said
on tape last week, we've taken over 60% of Gaza and we're going
to keep it and we're going to going to take over 70% of Gaza.
Somebody shouts out, "Take 100." And he says, "One thing at a
time." basically. So, David Wood knows that and goes, but he
wants to lie to everybody in America because he's not he doesn't
care about America, he cares about Israel. And and and so there
is no lie he wouldn't tell for Israel. So, also true of Ben Shapiro
and Mark Levin and Laura Loomer, et cetera. It's not true of
everyone who's >> All of those names, that's 100% true
for >> For Israel, but it is certainly true of those people.
And so there is a category that says, "Yes, we love to lie to
you." Like the number one lie is, "Iran is about to have a nuclear
weapon." They all know that's not true. They all know that Iran
doesn't even have a weapon that could deliver a missile that
could deliver that weapon even if it were built, which isn't
built. So, but they all purposely lie about it so they can trick
you, deceive you into supporting Israel. OH MY GOD. >> UH
THEY'VE GOT A MISSILE BUILT. Did he just say they don't have
a missile? They don't have the >> Oh, there is a category
that says, "Yes, we love to lie to you." Like the number one
lie is, "Iran is about to have a nuclear weapon." They all know
that's not true. They all know that Iran doesn't even have a
weapon that could deliver a missile that could deliver that weapon
even if it were built, which isn't built. >> I do think
they have ballistic missile
I No, I think they have ballistic missile tech. They don't have
the the weaponized version of the explosive.
In terms of ballistic missiles, they've got the missile tech.
I don't know, that's weird that he's saying they don't have the
missile that could deliver it. I don't think I don't think that
part is very difficult. Although, that would be another part
of a weapons test. They don't have the actual core explosive
device, the trigger, the smaller explosive that causes the fissile
material to start like interacting in a way that triggers the
chain reaction. They don't have that set up yet and they've never
done a missile test. So, like if you've never Sorry, they've
never done a weapons test. If you've never even a nuclear bomb,
in my opinion.
>> So, but they all purposely lie about it so they can
trick you, deceive you into supporting Israel. Oh my god, is
that a trope? Well, then Israel lies about everything. Every
official government statement has been proven false. It's empirical
and we've tracked it, right? They say, "Yes, but since we invented
this thing called a trope, which by the way no other race or
religion has. You can insult other races and religions and there
is no tropes, so you won't be banned, you won't be canceled,
it's fine, right? But if you say it about Israel, well, that's
it. Even though you're all totally correct, we're going to ban
you anyway. We're going to cancel you anyway. But we're not in
charge." Why is this country the size of Papua
Guinea laid down all these like not just rules but laws in the
United States and the United Kingdom? It doesn't make any sense.
So, they they owe us an apology. And not an apology, an explanation.
>> These guys these guys go crazy now.
Hold on, how long is it until Hasan comes on? >> that both
Hasan and I are here, we're you're at serious risk of public
disorder. So, mayhem [clears throat] might break out at any second
now. >> Can I start off with something a little different?
So, we're going to talk about Cenk and Hasan getting banned from
the UK, but I see this as part of a broader campaign targeting
you, Hasan, I don't like being put in a situation where I have
to defend you. I'm just going to keep it 100. Uh, but
uh, sorry, that's very funny. Listen, I straight up hate you,
bro.
But I will defend your right to say stupid [__] Hasan.
I'll defend your right to be a stupid himbo on the internet,
Hasan. I straight up despise you, bro.
I will defend your right to be a piece of [__] okay?
I'll write that. >> Dave Rubin went on a show and claimed
that you harassed me and other women at work, which was a brazen
lie. I went out and said that it was a brazen lie. You never
once harassed me at work. What What do you think this is about?
And why do you think it's okay, or why do they think it's okay
to just make up lies about you like that? I mean, like harassment
is a serious allegation. And >> That's so true, Anna. Why
do they
just feel like a pathological need to lie? That's so true. I
never thought about it that way. They
do feel the need to lie a lot, don't they? It's
>> And for Dave Rubin, who I haven't spoken to in over
a decade, to speak on my behalf like that and make something
up is insane. >> Yeah, I think it's a
>> Cenk looks so uncomfortable when when >> What
do you think this is about? And why do you think it's okay, or
why do they think it's okay to just make up lies about you like
that? I mean, like harassment is a serious allegation. And for
Dave Rubin, who I haven't spoken to in over a decade, to speak
on my behalf like that and make something up is >> Yeah,
I think it's it's a campaign of >> I think he's just so
uncomfortable when he's not talking.
I think that's what it is. If Cenk's not talking, he's concerned.
>> and and smearing prominent critics of Israel no matter
which way they can. And it's very obvious that they're getting
increasingly more desperate. Now, with Dave Rubin, it's a unique
predicament because on the one hand I'm thinking like, is this
a part of a broader sophisticated smear campaign, or rather is
it simply just Dave Rubin being stupid cuz he's just so unbelievably
stupid. So, with Dave Rubin, you got to think about both of the
options. >> But yeah, I do I do see a coordinated effort.
Fox News is probably watching this broadcast right now. They
have people stationed on my broadcast every single day. They
just do like a like a transcript readout of every single thing
that I talk about and and post about it and publish it. On the
other side, this is obviously escalated since the subpoena, which
I never received, by the But Will Cain was was talking about
how like some some counter protesters that were at the Delany
facility in New Jersey that I went to with Adam Hamawi, who's
running for Congress in New Jersey, to to check out the the uh
heinous conditions inside of the facility and to hear from the
protesters about the ways in which the state troopers in New
Jersey and the federal ICE officers were actually brutalizing
them for exercising their first amendment rights. Uh there were
a lot of agitators, a lot of counter protesters who were pro-ICE
and disruptors that were there uh specifically to yell at the
uh protesters. They of course yelled at me as well. And Will
Cain earlier today covered that uh as though it was actually
the the ICE protesters that were yelling at me. So, I feel like
there is a there's this like effort to to slander and and smear
uh prominent critics of Israel, prominent critics of the Trump
administration uh no matter which way they can. Uh there's obviously
uh a a bipartisan effort in some respects. Josh Gottheimer earlier
today also said I was cuz I called the the Israel Day parade
that took place that had Bezalel Smotrich on a Nazi parade. I
said there's Nazis at this parade. It's a Nazi parade and prominent
Democrats like Chuck Schumer and Kathy Hochul were participating
in a Nazi parade and and Josh Gottheimer didn't like that. Uh
and he was saying, you know, I've defended Hamas and therefore,
you know, maybe my my read for who's a Nazi is broken. Uh he's
been ducking me. I've told him I'd be willing to have you know,
like regular discourse with him. Um
>> And I it is funny that how do I put it? It's
it's very difficult in the current environment to cut through
with anything close to the truth. Like and I can as somebody
who was covering Hasan when it was like a lot of in my opinion
like solid criticisms that were happening. If they if they were
lies, they were like way way way more subtle lies that were like
they were like distortions. They weren't lies. You know what
I mean? >> Well, I mean, what's the substance of his argument?
Is you can't defend the indefensible. We all see what's happening
in Gaza. We all see what's happening in Lebanon. We see the entire
global economy being destroyed right now as we speak because
of this war that the US got dragged into against Iran by Israel.
So, I just feel like look, everything that's happening right
now, they think it's going to work. Like these bans, they think
it's going to work. The censorship, they think it's going to
work. Everyone sees what's going on and in fact, everything they're
doing is actually incredibly counterproductive to what they want
to accomplish here. >> Yeah. So, Hasan, to that point,
how do you think that the rest of this plays out, right? And
I don't mean about the UK. We'll come back to them in terms of
whether we're ever allowed to go there again. I mean, it's hilarious.
You were just there a little while ago. I was just there a little
while ago. Mayhem didn't break out. The public order wasn't immediately
destroyed, right? But like, so the it feels like the powerful
in in the US and the UK and a lot of Western countries, but not
all of them, are starting to tighten their grip and that they've
lost the media wars. But now the overwhelming majority of British
citizens and American citizens are on our side, not their side.
So, how does this movie end?
>> I mean, I I think inevitably there's going to be too
much public pressure and once there's too much public pressure,
governments like our government here in the United States and
governments in the UK and in in you know, far beyond in Europe
as well, are going to have to make a decision. Do they want to
drop all pretense that they have a democratic process, that they
care about like liberal humanitarian values, that they claim
to espouse, they claim to care about, or are they going to increase
the repression? And unfortunately,
what a lot of people either don't understand or are moving in
the direction of is exactly that. What did the UK >> Oh.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Hassan suddenly arguing for liberalism. Dude, the liberalism,
but only for the people I like crowd is going to get so mad about
this. I well, this is from yesterday, so I'm guessing they're
already really mad about it. You know what I mean? Like, I don't
I stand up for liberal values,
but not for everybody. That crowd, they're going to be so mad
about this interview right there. >> They they prescribed
Palestine Action as a terrorist organization and then they started
arresting en masse thousands of pensioners,
you know, disabled protesters, young people that would dare to
say that they support Palestine Action. Um >> Well, they're
so dangerous. They're so dangerous. All those elderly people
that they rounded up and arrested, so dangerous. And by the way,
Haz, you know, Cenk alluded to the fact that you were in the
UK not that long ago. And I want to show everyone what you were
talking about when you were in the UK not too long ago. Let's
take a look at >> Anti-semitism is a canary in the coal
mine of fascism. It's one of the oldest bigotries that has caused
those of the Jewish faith a tremendous amount of pain. From pogroms
to the Holocaust, have always been singled out by those in power
as a scapegoat for instability and economic volatility people
in power cause. A resilient nascent anti-semitism is a constant
threat, especially as economic instability makes those in power
seek out old targets. They're not very creative, usually. They
just always rehash the same propaganda over and over
This is precisely the reason why I am terrified of the conflation
of anti-Zionism and antisemitism. The conflation is dangerous.
>> I'm worried. I mean, things look very bleak. And, you
know, you pointed to the event that took place in New York City
over the weekend, and I want to kind of flush that out a little
bit for the audience in case they missed that story because,
you know, Israel's far-right finance minister Bezalel Smotrich
was seen in New York City alongside Democrats. This is for the
Israel Day parade over the weekend. Now, Zohran Mamdani, the
mayor of New York City, was just He was facing all this backlash
because he's the first mayor in 61 years who refused to attend
the Israel Day parade. And I'm glad that he did refuse considering
the fact that there was a literal war criminal there. So, let's
take a look at this J Street post on X. They write, "Bezalel
Smotrich should be sanctioned by American political and communal
leader leaders, not marching alongside them in the streets of
New York City. Smotrich is the architect of the Israeli government's
policies to ultimately annex the West Bank said that it may be
just and moral to starve 2 million Gaza residents, but no one
in the world would let us. He is a supporter of greater Israel.
We all know what that is. Believes Palestinians aren't even real
people or a people." >> Oh, jstreet.org.
It's so crazy when you like start actually paying attention.
You see the J Street thing and it's like, "Oh, this is just like
a total op."
I see how people who oppose Israel like slowly get either portrayed
or truly become schizophrenic cuz it's like you start to connect
patterns. It's like, "Oh, the J Street thing? They're just trying
to like reestablish
AIPAC under a different name with like policies that are more
aligned with the American people so they can still subtly influence."
but if you say that to somebody normal, they're like, "Oh, you're
you're like way too tapped. You're like crazy. You're like totally
crazy." It's like, "No, I'm I'm not crazy. I just see what's
happening, okay? I just see what's happening." >> And is
you know, someone who has played a huge role in annexing parts
of the West Bank, forcing people Palestinians namely out of their
homes. He's the International Criminal Court even has a warrant
out for his arrest. Take a look at this headline, exclusive ICC
prosecutor's office seeks arrest warrant for Israel's Smotrich.
>> Oh, no.
Hold on. I thought
That's not good. Wait, is this a bad look for Mondani? I could
have sworn that Mondani said
if Benjamin Netanyahu steps foot in New York City, I will arrest
him.
How did Bezalel Smotrich with an with a warrant from from the
ICC? How did he step foot in New York City and not get
I thought that was the bar. I thought I thought Oh, Mondani shouldn't
have said that. Okay.
They're seeking to get one. Oh, seeks arrest warrant. Yes, true.
Seeks. My bad. My bad. They don't have one. Seeks.
>> He's marching alongside Chuck Schumer and a whole host
of other Democrats at this parade over the same weekend that
you and Cenk get banned from the UK because you speak out against
these
>> It's a flex. The there's no other way to read it than
it's a flex. They're they're flexing on us. There's no other
way to read it as anything but a direct
a direct threat to what the American government or what the American
public has to say. That's what I think is going on. It's about
sending a message. That's why Bezalel Smotrich is there. Um And
and you brought up J Street and I find that really funny cuz
like liberal Zionism is inherently contradictory. This is one
of the things that people get very mad at me about because I
say liberal Zionism is like saying you're a liberal Nazi because
Zionism is racism. Zionism is Nazism. And
>> and a lot of people get very frustrated with this. And
and as a matter of fact
>> I It does have to be said that basically everybody,
every person I hear preach about liberal values doesn't seem
to really uphold those values.
Like it seems like a a ideology at this point of convenience
for people and I don't understand why cuz the values seem pretty
good. But like I see people using like a incorporating a lot
of populist rhetoric as liberals, right? And populist rhetoric
purely to destroy other people, purely to denigrate other people.
Not even like to espouse their values as good.
Which is why I think you would like use populist rhetoric in
general to mostly espouse your values as good.
yeah, the liberal populist movement in America is getting very
spooky to me at this point. >> Uh now that the all these
atrocities has made us look back and you uh we were taught um
uh in America when I was growing up here that 1948 was the Arabs
attacked the poor Israelis for no reason at all and like the
Israelis were the victims. Now you realize no, it was ethnic
cleansing. That's what the Nakba was. Uh they drove out 750,000
uh Palestinians from their lands, they slaughtered them and killed
them and that's why people had to run. Uh and so >> I mean
Uh yeah, do do
I think the Palestinians have a legitimate grievance for '48.
But it's not like these two sides weren't slowly like proceeding
towards a war before that, right? I mean I think I think they
literally had some sort of like civil war Palestinian civil war
of of a sort
in the year year and a half before this, right? They were literally
fighting each other, no?
Anyway, I
There's a lot of fighting going on on both sides. I think the
Israelis were quite a bit better organized and
end up winning and pushing people out
Like I don't I I think they definitely did like war crimes and
[__] I'm just saying it's not Palestinian grievance
is valid.
Okay? But I I don't think it's like that the Israelis the Israelis
weren't just like this evil overwhelming occupying force. That's
not that's not how I see it, but >> Our media lied to us
about that. They lied to us about >> One side lived there,
the other side was invading. Yes. Yes, they were invading in
a slow, like deliberate, overtime way. Sure. >> 1967, where
again Israel attacked its neighbors, we were told that they were
attacked. It's just not true. Now people go, "Oh yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah. Well, of course we lied about that." So, I understand
all that background, no question about it. And so, when you look
back at it, should they have done this, you know, this Zionism
idea, which has ethnic cleansing built into it in order to be
a settler colony? Now, that seems hard to defend, certainly.
Now, Israel already exists. So, if today
Israel and and and the Palestinian city has made a deal and they
had two states, assume for a second that that's remotely possible,
and it >> I will say there is something also to be said
for the fact that I do believe when when settlers came to Palestine
originally, they just represented it as like they wanted a connection
back to the land. And I do think the idea of the aliyahs and
stuff was explicitly to get enough of a population there to found
a Right? That was like explicitly the idea. That was the goal.
And so,
it was essentially like a lie that people knew was a lie at the
time. Like they would tell the Palestinians, "No, no, no, no,
we we will like have a country together." But they knew that
they were not going to form a country together, or at least it
became very clear to them at some point once they started fighting
with each other, right? Through the 19 the early 1900s, it became
very obvious to them, "Hey, we're never going to be able to have
a state with these people. We don't think so. So, we're going
to start coming up with plans for how we're going to push all
these people out if we have to." >> It was based on the
1967 borders, and they were both two independent safe states.
I would take that deal in a second, no matter how wrong Zionism
was in the beginning. Would you take that deal, or do you think
that's This is Zionism is wrong and it's
>> Oh, I I personally think that it's just not up to me.
I I I I think that whatever is good for the Palestinians, like
Palestinian statehood is good for the Palestinians, that's what
they're trying to move towards. If that means that there is a
two-state deal with 1967 borders and Palestinians are happy with
that, then who am I might have them no? Um, my am I'm a one stater
for the the reasons that you just brought up, right? Uh, and
there are some people who >> commitment to liberal values.
One person, one one person, one vote.
One person,
one vote, one country.
Like, everybody should have equal rights is why Hassan's a, you
know, one stater. >> actually disagree with me on this
as well. Um, but uh, the reason why I say I'm a one stater is
the same reason why Avi Shlaim also eventually arrived at that
same conclusion and I believe so did Ilan Pappé. These are two
very prominent new historians from Israel. They're They uh, they
uncovered uh, a lot of the uh, atrocities that took place during
the Nakba and after the Nakba as well. Avi Shlaim specifically
about uh, what the what the experience for uh, Arabs was like
moving to Israel and why they had to move to Israel. And then
Ilan Pappé specifically about Plan Dalet. So, their assessment
is uh, the same as mine. They look at 750,000
settlers that now illegally occupy both Eastern Jerusalem and
the rest of the West Bank, the occupied West Bank that is currently
occupied illegally by the Israeli state uh, to specifically design
a non-contiguous Palestinian state. Uh, and and the removal of
uh, uh, Jewish settlers from the uh, occupied West Bank is virtually
impossible.
Um, I don't think that they would ever do it. Israel had a very
hard time removing
>> Yeah, I when these people talk about that as an ideal,
Evil Johnny Bravo, nobody, not even Hassan, is arguing that tomorrow
it's all one country and everybody gets a vote and they live
together happily.
Literally, nobody's arguing that. Nobody is even remotely trying
to argue that. Obviously, that is not a thing that could happen
tomorrow.
Right? It's that is the guiding principle by which somebody operates,
right? That's the high-level principle. Is eventually needs to
get to that situation because anything other than that situation
will lead to one of these groups being oppressed.
Which I think is just foundationally
we would all accept as true if you believe in liberal values,
right? >> Settlers from uh, the the Sinai Peninsula at
the time and they had an even harder time removing only 7,000
Israeli uh >> Well, I just I'm highlighting Evil Johnny
Bravo's comment because I think that's like the counter
that's like the counter that a lot of people say, well, no, they
won't be able to do that. They they'll be a bunch of fighting
and people will die. And it's like, yeah, nobody's saying that
needs to happen tomorrow. Everybody's saying that is the ideological
goal you move towards, right?
They ever out load I don't know. I've never asked Hasan, hey,
what do you think? I would imagine he'd think like a well, pretty
much off the bat it's going to have to be like some kind of separation
and slow integration over time. That's what LonerBox says and
LonerBox was a person who would argue for one state at certain
points like in the past as well. So, yeah, I don't I don't know.
Nobody's Nobody's saying tomorrow needs to be one person one
one vote. Like that it just probably doesn't work, right? It
would turn into violence immediately. Maybe you do one person
one vote and you like actually try to get that working and then
you have like a really really strong constitution or some some
third-party arbiter. Maybe you have like the United States or
or some arbitration body that's outside of the country that resolves
like if one side is doing laws that are going to negatively affect
the other side, right? Maybe something along the along these
lines, but they probably need like a referee for a while.
Nobody wants to do it though. >> Um with the Democratic
Party, uh a lot of people get mad at me for saying this as well,
but I I see a very weak party. The party uh is not a real party,
right? It's a it's a coalition of different corporate interests
and you know, foreign lobbies at times. Uh and by foreign lobbies
I just mean Israel, let's be real. There isn't like a like a
profound Estonian lobby that is dominating Democ >> Dude,
okay, hold on. Man, this is how I feel as well.
There are some issues here where like the Dems, this is part
of the fundraising issues they're having,
How do you get a strong Democratic Party that can exert any force
that could give itself any strong identity when the DNC can't
raise money?
Like how how do you how does that happen? You can't, right? There
cannot be a coherent
and
a coherent and strong Democratic Party with no money there at
all. It's just a bunch of people bickering. There is no arbiter.
There is nothing going on.
It's so weak.
>> Democratic Party attitudes if we're being real, but
there is a there is a real disconnect between those who are voting
for the Democrats and what their demands are and what the Democrats
are willing to concede to on those demands. And therefore, I
see this as a wonderful opportunity in all of this weakness to
force in as many responsive politicians in this insurgent Bernie-crat
coalition that is forming all around the country. There are plenty
of Democratic socialists who are open socialists and even those
who aren't socialists, but
>> Dude, I hope I hope very badly that your guys's like
sort of like left-wing movements
can survive the death of Bernie Sanders. I'm going to be honest
cuz he like realistically this guy is what? 84 now? 85? 86?
How old is Bernie? He's he old as man.
84, okay. He's 84.
There's a guy in Canada who had a like a left-wing party that
was coming up named Jack Layton and he was like the best He he
was awesome. He was an awesome political leader. Very inspiring
guy,
And that party straight up collapsed the second he died. Like
like like obliterated itself. You need somebody who can like
actually stand up business and tell a lot of the disparate interests
in like a left-wing coalition that their thing is not important
enough to put over the party. And it's very difficult to find
somebody who's not strong enough to because you can just you
can essentially kowtow to a couple of those interests and gain
control of the same party.
The same coalition.
You need some like a unique personality that can stand up against
that and say no no no no no no no. We're going to put the party
ahead of everybody. We're going to have like this this message
that's going to unite
And who do you think is the best shot to replace Bernie? It could
be Elsa Aid. I I need to hear Elsa Aid speak more.
I just think there's something to a guy that like works that
hard that could be very uniting. Anyway, you need you need somebody
who's strong enough to keep those disparate coalitions from essentially
uniting under someone who's weaker but will prioritize those
And I don't know it it takes a very special person. I think Bernie
gives a very consistent message that doesn't just pander to specific
groups all the And I don't know that there will be another sort
of Bernie-crat type leader who will know not to do that or be
strong enough not to do that. >> Yep. All right. So everybody
check out Hasan's show on Twitch but you can also see clips on
YouTube so check out his channel there as well. >> I just
hope Ana Kasparian bookends this interview with like just reminder
Haz, I straight up hate you bro. I just just so you know, I don't
want to let you get away without hearing it a third time. I despise
you guy. I despise you and everything you stand for but I do
think you should be allowed in England. What did the brofessor
do to her? I think I think Ana Kasparian just thinks she's way
smarter than Hasan
and that Hasan's success is unearned.
I think she basically decided she was going to be a real news
person and Hasan went like the the
like the pop idol route kind of to her and I think she's got
a lot of I think she's got a lot of like uh resentment because
Hasan was so much more successful going that route when she probably
could have been extremely successful going that route.
Just like the first 12 seconds of this. What is this? >> Uh
just be anti-racist. Let's be your mainstream shows. Cenk Uygur,
did you know Jimmy Kimmel featured one of Hasan's tweets on last
night's show? >> Everyone loves Hasan. He's super famous
and rich. We got it. >> Did she so awesome? She's so real.
She's she's so real.
I'm a huge Ana Kasparian fan, okay?